[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci merci mon ami
je m'excuse
je crois que j'ai oublié quelque chose
on va pas se mentir ici quand la
personne que vous allez voir arriver
avec ce fauteuil roulant et la personne
que vous voyez devant vous je pense que
la première vous ai dit c'est une
personne handicapée
et que là vous voyez un speaker devant
vous on est d'accord
je vais pas vous juger
j'ai aussi porté ce regard
je l'ai porté à
avant d'expérimenter ce fauteuil roulant
ce fauteuil roulant
il m'a accompagné pendant toute ma vie
il a été mon meilleur ami
il a été là dans tout mon quotidien
alors oui j'essaie de quoi le regard il
parle mais avant de vous parler de ce
fauteuil roulant encore plus longuement
laissez-moi me présenter
je m'appelle Steven
je suis entrepreneur plus précisément
cet apreneur c'est à dire que je lance
des activités grâce à Instagram
je suis né au Bénin je sais pas si
certains
oui
c'est un tout petit pays en Afrique de
l'Ouest
je suis né dans une famille de 9 enfants
dont j'étais le dernier le 9e
par contre je suis né avec 1,5 cm de
différence entre mes deux hanches entre
mes deux jambes
mes parents ne m'ont jamais fait
ressentir son handicap
il ne m'indiquez pas non plus pour jouer
au football j'étais plutôt jouer j'étais
plutôt doué pour jouer au football
j'ai des recruteurs français qui sont
venus au Bénin et qui m'ont détecté
ainsi que j'ai plus j'ai pu avoir la
chance d'intégrer la GIA le centre de
formation de Auxerre à l'âge de 14 ans
j'étais ravi de pouvoir vivre de ma
passion
jusqu'à ce jour
où je me fais ta clé violemment
je ne puisse plus marcher
il y a des enfants qui font la tournée
des confiseries la tournée des manèges
avec leurs parents et ben moi avec mon
père c'était la tournée des hôpitaux
d'hôpital à l'hôpital le verdict était
toujours le même je me souviens encore
de ce regard de ce spécialiste à la
Pitié-Salpêtrière qui a dit à mon père
la marche pour votre fils monsieur c'est
fini il ne marchera plus jamais
je vous parle pas de la colère que
j'avais à ce moment-là de la haine que
j'avais à ce moment-là dépenser qui
m'ont traversé à ce moment-là
comment ça je ne peux plus marcher hier
j'étais valide sportif
Joël avenir dans le football et
aujourd'hui je suis dans un fauteuil
roulant je peux même pas marcher tu peux
même pas courir
ou pas ce jour-là ça a été le meilleur
jour de ma vie parce que mon père il m'a
sorti cette phrase qui a fait de moi la
personne que je suis aujourd'hui
c'est sa réalité mon fils ce n'est pas
ta réalité il dit des bêtises le médecin
je marche tes frères et sœurs marche tu
as marché tu marcheras encore
alors ce n'était pas facile
j'ai passé plusieurs années dans ce
fauteuil roulant
mais ce fauteuil roulant m'a permis
d'expérimenter plusieurs regards
le regard protecteur de mon père je vous
parle de cette partie de mon père
mais au Bénin faut savoir dans les
années 80 qu'on était dans une société
prête à faire qu'elle les hommes d'un
côté les femmes de l'autre
j'avais une passion quand je t'ai tout
petit je joue avec les poupées de mes
sœurs et mon père m'interdisait de le
faire encore moins de leur confectionner
des habits
mon fils ce n'est pas viril tu ne peux
pas faire ça
on lui dirait pas que j'ai la scène
depuis
non il m'a beaucoup soutenu dans le
lancement de la marque
juste avant
papa et maman s'était dit que c'est pour
vous merci pour tout
[Applaudissements]
expérimenter un autre regard
c'est le regard de l'exclusion du
handicap de la maladie
on a tous regardé une personne qui était
différente de nous d'une autre façon et
ben j'étais la personne qui subissait ce
regard
quand j'étais tout petit on me sortait
cette phrase
on me Surma du prénom du surnom de à
dropo à propos ça veut dire lézard ma
façon de marcher à Elsa façon saccadée
de ramper
ils sont terribles les enfants
le pire je me souviens de ce jeune homme
Yannick je me souviens encore de son
prénom qui me sort cette phrase avec ton
pied et demi tu n'auras jamais une femme
encore moins un enfant tu ferais mieux
de te pendre
quelle violence je suis content de
savoir aujourd'hui qui a des campagnes
pour aider les adolescents contre le
harcèlement scolaire
ça aurait bien fait du bien à l'époque
j'expérimenté un autre regard
celui de la différence
celui de la différence Liam à couleur de
peau
il y a quelques années je travaille dans
une maison de luxe nous avons les
meilleurs performances commerciales 3
années de suite nous avons eu les
meilleurs chiffre d'affaires les
meilleurs chiffre d'affaires de l'Europe
entier avec mes équipes cela va être le
meilleur le plus jeune directeur à Gérin
centre de profit à 28 ans
j'ai postulé pour un poste plus haut le
directeur de son d'Europe refus après
refus je ne comprenais pas jusqu'à ce
soir au détour dans couloir j'entends
cette phrase qui résonne encore
aujourd'hui
on y va quand même pas mettre un noir à
la tête de l'Europe
on le va quand même pas mettre un noir à
j'ai une super anarchique une directrice
qui a remplacé mon directeur de l'époque
qui a tenu cette phrase
alors pour moi il était temps de quitter
cette entreprise
bien entendu j'ai quitté cette
entreprise depuis je suis devenu
entrepreneur et je fais plein d'autres
choses dans ma vie
j'aurais pu rester dans le confort
puisque je vais bien ma vie j'aurais pu
rester dans cette entreprise mais pour
moi il était hors de question
cette phrase elle a même poussé beaucoup
de choses j'ai décidé de faire attention
j'ai décidé d'acheter des vêtements
luxueux j'ai décidé d'acheter des objets
de luxe j'ai décidé même de travailler
dans le luxe en fait je suis resté dans
le luxe pendant 10 ans
jusqu'à ce que j'entende cette phrase on
va quand même pas mettre un noir à la
tête de l'Europe
alors je me suis rendu compte que
dépenser
de l'argent juste pour impressionner les
gens n'avaient pas de sens
pour moi il fallait partir de l'essence
partir des difficultés partir des fois
des points faibles de ces personnes afin
de faire en sorte d'améliorer l'image et
c'est ce que je me suis permis de faire
je ne sais pas si dans cette salle il y
en a qui connaissent browniewer
non oui
était infirmière
elle a noté cinq regrets de ces
personnes en fin de vie et elle a décidé
de faire un livre
je n'ai pas vous citer les cinq
malheureusement on n'aura pas le temps
de toute expérimenter mais j'en ai
retenu trois
quitter mon entreprise avec ce fait pour
me lancer
le premier regret qu'elle a constaté
c'était vivre sa vie et non celle des
autres
vive sa vie et non celle des autres
c'est plus ça comme phrase non
quand vient dans le monde
on nous dit
d'aller à l'école dès le premier de la
classe de faire des études le travail
d'avoir un bon job et j'ai fait tout
ceci j'étais dans ce fameux schéma
jusqu'à ce jour où le téléphone sonna ma
sœur
allô c'est papa comment ça papa a eu un
AVC
il aurait pu partir quelques secondes
près mais Dieu merci il est encore parmi
nous
ce jour-là aussi a été dans ma vie je me
suis dit que je ne vivrai plus la vie
des autres j'étais en train de vivre la
vie de mes parents j'ai fait des études
de management à Cambridge qu'est-ce que
j'ai travaillé pour avoir ce Bachelor
j'ai fait des études en marketing de
lutte j'ai fait des études en finance
MBA et en fait j'étais en train de vivre
une vie pour mes parents qui n'avaient
pas fait d'étude et en fait je ne
passais pas du temps avec mes parents
tout cela pour vivre pour vivre la reine
je vous en supplie vivez pour vous et
pas pour les autres c'est ce que j'ai
décidé de faire depuis et je m'en vais
très bien
le deuxième regret c'est vivre en
cachant ses sentiments
vous avez ici devant vous une personne
un garçon qui a 1,5 cm de différent
entre ces deux jambes
la médecine a fait des progrès depuis
bon j'aurais pu faire des progrès
ailleurs mais bon ça c'est autre chose
j'ai été blessé par les enfants de mon
âge j'ai été blessé par les adolescents
et j'ai beaucoup gardé sur moi je n'ai
jamais voulu exprimer mes sentiments
mais en fait à partir du moment où j'ai
essayé d'accéder à 14 ans je me suis dit
qu'elle aurait fini et vous avez devant
vous un jeune homme qui de deux lettres
de 2 mois a sorti cette phrase je
démissionne je travaille dans une
superbe maison de joinville-le-luxe en
France
je n'étais pas allé avec ce qui faisait
ça ne se passait pas bien il ne me
parlait pas comme je le méritais j'ai
décidé de quitter cette entreprise on ne
peut pas partir comme ça me dit ma
responsable vous me manquez de respect
donc je prends le droit de partir
crois-moi que ça a été difficile une
année sans le sous
une année de galère mais si c'était à
refaire je referai aujourd'hui car j'ai
pu rebondir après de ses échecs
peut-être que des personnes ici dans
cette salle sont venues avec des
personnes dont ils sont amoureuses et ne
le disent pas et ne le disent pas je
vous invite à le dire peut-être que des
personnes ont fait sale ne parle pas de
leur sexualité à leurs parents je vous
invite à le faire peut-être que des
personnes ici dans cette salle
ont des problèmes on devrait parler à
leurs amis ne cachez pas vos sentiments
la vie c'est 80 ans
le troisième regret dont j'aimerais vous
parler
c'est vivre sa cordon le droit et le
devoir être heureux
vivre sa cordon le devoir et le droit
d'être heureux êtes-vous heureux
je vous pose la question
si on échelle de 10 vous donnerai
combien
c'est difficile comme question non
je ne parle pas du savoir qu'on te
demande comment ça va ça va
je sais très bien
si ça va
tu me l'a supposé cette question pendant
longtemps
il a passé des années en prison
a été président d'Afrique du Sud elle a
mis un prix Nobel de la paix
Nelson Mandela
il a écrit l'alectrocuté à 20000 volts
sa femme l'a quitté il a été en plus
tard avec des moyens il a traversé la
Manche à la nage il a fait un
Paris-Dakar il a fini 47e devant 5
personnes valides
il a même rejoint les équipes d'hélon
Philippe couillon
il avait plus le sous et c'était sa
dernière chance
aujourd'hui faire rêver aussi bien les
enfants que les adultes
Walt Disney
il a traversé le Cameroun à Lana il a
été arrêté quand il est venu elle était
traité de migrants et a fini SDF pendant
longtemps aujourd'hui les champions du
monde de MMA français - Sénégal
je ne sais pas vous mais moi tous ces
personnes m'inspire personne respire
moins inspiré fondé moi la personne que
je suis aujourd'hui ces personnes ont
été combiné à l'échelle d'entreprise de
décider des hommes politiques des stars
que j'ai interviewé devant toute ma vie
pour avoir sur ma chaîne
quand même toutes ces personnes
c'est qu'elles ont décidé que peu
importe le regard que les personnes
porterait sur elle elle en avait que
faire
c'est donc décidé que pas à part le
regard de mes parents
peu importe le regard de mes amis
d'enfance ou plutôt camarade enfance peu
importe le regard de ma directrice
peu importe le regard des réseaux
sociaux
ces regards tous ces regards ne sont pas
des excuses
tous ces regards ne sont pas des excuses
pour ne pas avancer comme je suis tous
ces regards ne sont pas des obstacles
mais plutôt ce que vous décidez d'en
faire
j'aimerais qu'on partage ensemble
une expérience ici
ça vous parle
je vous invite à vous lever tous
je vous invite à regarder pendant 10
secondes le voisin ou la voisine de
votre gauche
et pendant 10 secondes
de droite
d'accord à gauche
à droite
[Musique]
merci
ça fait bizarre non
qu'est-ce que tu fais bizarre est-ce que
le jugement que vous partez sur la
personne à côté de vous à bizarre où
est-ce que c'est le jugement que cette
personne porte sur vous que vous qui
vous sont
dernière chose vous souvenez de Yannick
il avait dit que avec ma jambe et demi
que je n'aurais ni femme ni enfant et
que je ferais mieux de me pendre
aujourd'hui j'ai rencontré une femme
formidable qui partage ma vie
et je suis le papa d'un petit garçon
Gabriel avec qui on a beaucoup d'amour
je remercie le ciel de ne pas me
suicider je remercie le sel de ne pas
être pendu
alors bien sûr j'ai peur
qu'on me demande si j'ai pas peur que
mon fils est le même gêne que moi chez
la B27 et la même pathologie
la peur n'évite pas le danger mais en
tout cas au quotidien je lui donne la
confiance nécessaire afin qu'il puisse
se libérer du regard des autres j'avais
toutes les excuses pour ne pas y arriver
et pourtant je l'ai fait
vous aussi vous pouvez le faire surtout
vous croyez en vous personne ne le fera
pour vous merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]